sin muy buenas noches desde nueva york
post y el discurso de nicolás maduro
médico las madura ha terminado hace un
poco más de media hora y precisamente ha
vuelto como decías a cargar contra eeuu
por esas medidas coercitivas
unilaterales y sanciones a las que tiene
sometido al pueblo al pueblo venezolano
ha dicho además ha hecho hincapié en que
eeuu es el peor enemigo del
multilateralismo la única forma de
acabar con esta pandemia maduro ha dicho
a eeuu que en el pleno siglo 21 el mundo
entero le mira y que no es tarde para
empezar a respetar la carta de las
naciones unidas y para acabar con la
presión sobre el pueblo venezolano ha
querido resaltar también su buena
gestión de esta pandemia ha dicho que
está ofreciendo venezuela ofrece
tratamientos gratuitos contra la cob y
19 y que han superado las expectativas
de pruebas contra el virus incluso ha
dicho que muchos venezolanos han vuelto
a su país después de que los territorios
en los que se encontraban no hubiesen
hecho una buena gestión de la pandemia
madura ha querido recordar también estas
elecciones que tendrán lugar el 6 de
diciembre ha dicho que se van a celebrar
con todas las garantías y recordemos que
ya
el secretario general antonio guterres
una comisión para que controlara estas
elecciones muy pendientes como decías de
la intervención en redes sociales que
hará el líder opositor venezolano juan
guaidó que se dirigirá a las
delegaciones de esta asamblea dice para
explicar lo que millones de venezolanos
quieren decir y pedir la libertad de
venezuela muy bien más pensarlo muchas
gracias por tu reporte desde nueva york